hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
so fallout 76 has officially had its
reveal and takes the post-apocalyptic
role-playing game into a new direction
in the 20-minute presentation and
subsequent press release info we can now
piece together everything we know about
fallout 76 so let's start off with the
biggest change to fallout fallout 76
will be the first Fallout title to be
entirely set online in a multiplayer
format this means we'll be wandering the
wasteland with our friends I don't know
about you but that one piece of
information is all I truly needed to
know although we haven't had
confirmation on how many players we can
fit in one squad the pictures shown in
the presentation look to make this a
four player experience but we could find
other people in the open-world to add to
our boyband
what looks really interesting though is
will you be a fun-loving crew built for
justice or more of a villainous troop of
anti-heroes it looks like there's room
for both ways to play in terms of story
the year is 2100 to 25 years after the
nuclear bombs have obliterated humanity
which makes fallout 76 a prequel to the
other Fallout titles we survived all
this nastiness in a West Virginian
fallout shelter known as vault 76 one of
the few vaults when no experiments were
conducted on the survivors instead this
vault was filled with the nation's
greatest minds and brightest talents and
our reward for this is to be one of the
first bolts opened in the new slightly
burnt world the obvious ear of vault 76
has tasked us with reclaiming nuclear
warheads from around the open world
which require activation codes which so
happened to be on things we kill such as
creatures and other players in the game
giving the game a survival element and
speaking of survival Fallout games have
always focused on human survival but
only to a mild degree have you ever
played rust
maybe h1z1 before the Battle Royale
invasion or seven ways to die or the
forest come to think of it survival
games are quite plentiful fallout 76 is
following in the footsteps of many of
these games but without the depressing
stress of losing everything in a single
moment instead fallout suggests a soft
core version of survival in which death
doesn't cost your characters progression
also fallout 76 isn't trying to push a
battle royale mentality
Last Man Standing there isn't thousands
of other players to contend with the
figure is much lower it's more likely a
few dozen real players to share the
world with as your progression isn't
tied to a single server we'll be able to
join our friends and take everything
we've gathered and accomplished with us
don't think for a second though that
this world is a friendly loving hell no
it's as cutthroat as you want it to be
at any moment a friend could become an
enemy so we'll all have to be vigilant
and a little bit sadistic to
shut up there sport so how do you know
which enemy is a real person and who
want to have controls the NPC's in
wildlife fallout 76 plans to have every
single human being in the game played by
a real-life human being outside the game
so if you see a vault dweller like you
in the distance know that they are also
sat at home pretending to be ill to get
a day off work or school other potential
enemies such as this hulking beast of
that death claw or the occasional super
mutant will be controlled by the game's
AI making the game PvE VP the player
versus the environment with elements of
player versus player - as this is online
we need to talk about the brilliance of
the VAT system let's quickly recap it
vats is a targeting system used in many
Fallout games to slow down time and
select exact areas to end your weapon
towards without a doubt it's one of the
greatest mechanics in the series but
here's an issue will vats be here in
Fallout 76 well we'd have to say no it
wouldn't be possible to slow down time
without forcing other players in the
world just lowdown - so will that's
return in another way or will that
fantastic aiming methods be removed from
fallout 76 as I've already mentioned
we're in West Virginia this time in the
real world the US government house many
nuclear secrets in West Virginia as mere
mortals we're never going to find them
out but in the world of Fallout 76 we'll
be uncovering every government secret we
can across six distinct regions each
region will have their own visual style
enemy types and rewards to uncover the
map itself is over four times the size
of Fallout fours which was freaking huge
to say the least
we're also told that advances in
technology will allow for all new
rendering lighting and landscape
technology it allows us to have sixteen
times the detail and even view distant
weather systems across the map I won't
lie I don't have a clue what that even
means but it sounds freaking epic the
game will be broken into quest lines
allowing anyone to play alone if that
floats their boat but bethesda has
stated this will be a tough experience
alone and really pushed hard on the need
to play alongside friends for the best
experiences especially when it comes to
building a community what separates man
from Beast it is his desire
to build get started with hands fallout
76 introduces the camp's mechanic which
stands for construction and assembly
mobile platform which will be a huge
part of the game building on the pretty
deep crafting element found in fallout 4
camp allows us to build anywhere in the
open world using a range of items we
find around the wasteland what's pretty
cool here is that your entire settlement
can be moved across to another area of
the map with relative ease this will be
important because your lovely home will
be attacked regularly
it's even possible to be nuked nuclear
armament is a real threat in fallout 76
as I've already stated launch codes can
be found throughout the world but aren't
instantly complete they'll take
communication with other players to
fully obtain a cold after that it's a
simple case of fighting all the way to
the nuclear receiver before you can
finally drop a bomb on those pesky
neighbors who've been attacking your
settlement for weeks now let's be
serious this mechanic will be the
biggest griefing tool in fallout 76 so
how do you feel about it I'm not too
sure it worries me that all my hard work
in my settlement will be destroyed in
one single button press on the plus side
the items created by the blast radius
offer high-level rewards which we could
fight for as long as we have a hazmat
suit you know for health and safety
reasons the fate of this new world is
yours to command with the power of the
atom let's cover a few small things you
need to know to fallout 76 will have a
photo mode to save those moments of
celebration after a kill there'll also
be a bucket load of emotes to use - but
beneath all that are important little
tidbits fallout 76 most dedicated
servers which are committed to the game
for years to come this isn't a flash in
the pan expects rigorous support as the
concept requires a great deal of testing
before it's released fallout 76 will
have a beta period of beta period
however you like to say it which is a
reward for pre-order customers there's
also a bucket load of special editions
of the game with ridiculous and
brilliant things to look at the
collector's edition comes with the
obligatory game map that close the map
comes with character models to place on
said map but it gets even better and
even weirder there's a power armor
Edition which comes with a four scale
wearable t51 power armor helmet and
their back to keep it in damnit Bethesda
shut up and take my bottle caps the Tri
Centennial Edition offers loads of
in-game items such as power armor
customization weapon decals a vault boy
mascot a patriotic outfit a limited
edition emote a few posters and even a
picture frame to end all this fallout 76
is almost complete and get this it will
be released this year
November the 14th 2018 how freaking
brilliant is that so who is excited
about taking on the wasteland again yeah
me too please let me know what you're
looking forward to and what has you
worried the hype has caught up with me
so I'm going to order the power armor
helmet I'm Adam from Playstation grenade
it's been a pleasure I'll see you next
time take your friendly old neighbor
Johnny rather than coming over to borrow
a cup of sugar he may now be coming over
for murder the time has come